what do you think sparked you to go out
on your own versus continuing to work
for one of the big firms getting fired
I was always kind of a an independent a
little bit Rowdy kind of person
um and um and so I don't think I fit
very well into companies and I had a
boss he he was a good guy but like we
got drunk on New Year's Eve and I
punched them and we you know I mean it
was kind of not didn't fit well so I got
fired and that was one of the best
things that happened to me the clients
of the firm that I work for the
brokerage firm uh like dealing with me
so they paid for advice and and it was
great because I could then be on my own
and do the things I loved and make my
own path
so is that when you founded Bridgewater
Associates yeah 1975. I graduated from
school 1973.
and then I had the job for about two
years two jobs and then I and then I saw
a Bridgewater with when I say started
Bridgewater it was at a two-bedroom
apartment
I had a roommate who was in the other
bedroom and he moved out so I put our
office in that two-bedroom apartment and
I kept playing the game